welcome to this video wow that's what
kind of name is said I vain I don't know
now that that's not going to work well
me pronouncing that let's see linnemann
so probably I played a bit of Quincy to
recently no he's playing something
entirely non theoretical there should be
seven not really fighting much for the
center here okay so what am I going to
do probably five and gaining containing
spatium Queen g4 comes into
consideration sure looks good right just
happiness hanging a t4 is hanging if he
goes to Knight c3 I can even take on g7
intermediate move for castles I'm taking
e4 and I'm a porn up hmm
Joe that doesn't that doesn't look good
what's black supposed to do here yeah
that's probably a reason why nobody
plays Bishop e7 on move three giving why
the big center yeah as usual now now
black is taking time after he has
screwed up the whole thing dashing out
all this year like 11 seconds and then
their loss center invest a minute okay
yeah lost is a bit strong but it's a
pawn and no compensation okay so i
probably have to play Bishop to hear
it's a bit inconvenient but it's never
example like to compensate for the big
center pond okay i can go Bishop d3 here
for this temple them on h7 so it's
probably quite useful the reason why i
don't really think he has compensation
because of my king is that I have very
good central control and I'm better
developed even so I don't really see his
compensation here yeah this is probably
the relatively best try if I go d5 it
takes ed CD Bishop f5 stuff like that
probably I should just take when Queen
85 yeah maybe it's probably still not
enough but check it's a relatively good
try ok so i wonder if i should invest
the time here probably have a 3mp form
b6 now before wins the peace um yeah me
wants to go 94 here I guess yeah okay
it's not not a big deal i can go before
him and then rookie 194 i can take that
lettuce check really wow this is trading
queens that gives me a totally winning
endgame him now my king is excellently
placed and in the middle of the board
okay putting this on e four so that he
cannot easily develop his bishop and
then looked upon some probably look the
six or c5 what's best c5 maybe yep
preparing rook t6 yes Bishop a4 but i
can put it put the look on d6 nothing
nothing really that travels me so be
five
b5 you will take mikeosong better not I
mean probably I wouldn't be seven at the
end so even that was possible but he
would simply run out of museum black
resigns now a little kids of dashing out
a couple of moose in seconds and then
being lost yeah there should be seven is
just a mistake gives why the big center
simply no reason why black should allow
that I mean in comparison to some other
openings that say the Kings Indian the
Kings Indian black at least gets in like
d65 fighting the center arm benoni was
c5 where you give up the center
temporarily he has no counter play the
only way to to do something in the
center is d5 what he did and after ye
five yeah you in trouble now what are
you doing if you are going back I'm just
taking the center pawn it gives a bit of
counter play with c5 but it's never
going to be enough after this Queen g4 I
really don't see what black black should
do here this is just just miserable okay
what he what he did is he gave me the
spawn I could have played Bishop h6 here
by the way why didn't I consider that
hmm okay I took the pawn which is also
not bad but I've already I really should
have played that one jump basically wins
the exchange but check it says this is I
don't really think he asked compensation
okay a computer gifts gives him some
compensation with Bishop d7 this this
and computer gives equal that's tough to
believe really maybe I mean equal hmm I
don't know but Bishop c5 and then bishop
um to see success that's possible I mean
bishop age six was better anyway I
should have taken the exchange
yeah here temple has to do this Knight
f3 now I doubt that something is still
on here definitely not hear me you
should give several is again given by
the engine this is this is an
interesting try I'm trying to get the
bishop active them and I mean I
shouldn't really take right this is this
is falling falling apart for white so
what am I going to do then after Bishop
d7 d 5 i'm not sure this is what the
computer is giving now maybe at least
that limits the bishop and the bishop
end the night this this looks a bit
tricky but now that it should be good
for white even I mean the king is a
little bit bit of a problem but to send
the pawns and it's it's it's one extra
yeah okay the way it went check I think
he has he has absolutely nothing and he
has to move the Queen after that it's
really over the endgame is it's just
it's just very easy because white has
total control in addition to his pawn
yeah okay well thanks for watching